Україна має дуже коротка вікно
можливостей для того щоби цього року
розпочати офіційні переговори про вступ
до Європейського Союзу і ми маємо це
вікно можливостей максимально
використати Європейський союз сформував
всім напрямків сім реформ які від нас
очікує для того щоби зробити позитивний
висновок вже восени і розпочати ці
переговори якщо по деяким напрямкам
дійсно є успіхи зокрема це закон про
медіа закон про рекламу і ми дуже раді
що наша політична сила добилася щоби в
законі Про медіа були просто ліквідовані
всі ці спроби протягти туди знову
російську мову ми дуже раді що хоча би
якимось чином ми домоглися того що канал
Рада який я взагалі останні півтора року
не транслював парламент тепер змушений
бодай раз на місяць робити трансляцію в
запису пленарних засідань парламенту і
це є важливо то в деяких сферах у нас
повний нуль зокрема Європейський союз і
наша міжнародні партнери справедливо
наголошують на тому що варто повернути
декларування декларування чиновників ми
бачимо скільки тут є зловживань Наша
команда активно працює в робочій групі
по допрацюванню цього закону враховуючи
реалії часу тому що треба вирішити що
робити з людьми на окупованих територіях
чиновниками які там залишаються і як
вони мають декларуватися Вірніше не
декларуватися так само є проблема з
людьми які втратили все майно ось ці
питання мають бути вирішені прописані на
період воєнного часу але декларування
має повернутися і тут позиція
європейського солідарності є однозначною
але зверніть увагу в скількох законах
сьогодні в скількох напрямках є
абсолютно
безвідповідальна позиція буде
безвідповідальна позиція моно більшості
яка по суті ставить сьогодні під загрозу
початок офіційних перемовин щодо вступу
України до Європейського Союзу зокрема
мова іде про такі закони як
антиолігархічний закон і закон про
формування незалежного Конституційного
Суду щодо антиолігархічного закону тут є
розгромне абсолютно висновок
вінесійської комісії і наша фракція
наполягала на тому що боротьба з
олігархами - це боротьба з монополістами
монополіями і тут має бути посилення
антимонопольного комітету а не створення
розстрільної трійки у вигляді РНБО яка
буде в ручному режимі там кожного
неугодного і українця визначати
олігархом все це насправді сказала і
вони ціцька комісія і тому наш колега
Ростислав Павленко і Ніна южаніна дуже
активно сьогодні працюють над змінами до
антиолігархічного законопро- закону які
ми обов'язково
зареєструємо і подамо на ближчим часом
тепер
судно звісно закон про конституційний
суд європейська Солідарність першою
внесла законопроект який би враховував
ключову норму ключову практику
цивілізованої країни конституційний суд
має бути незалежним від влади і саме
тому ми пропонували щоб До речі група
експертів формувалася за тим же лекалом
що сформована ця група експертів яка
відбирає конкурсантів на суддів
антикорупційного суду не почули не
поставили наш законопроект в порядок
денний не врахували наші поправки коли
приймали закон про пенсійний суд більше
того призначили суддів з порушеннями
напхали туди суддів залежних від
банкової колишніх представників фракції
слуга народу і коли отримали розгромне
абсолютно висновок вони сільської
комісії прийняли законопроект Який Ну
знову-таки не відповідають тим
рекомендаціям які дає вони ціцька
комісія от в першому читанні цей
законопроект збалансовано Минулого тижня
європейська Солідарність зареєструвала
зміни на яких ми будемо наполягати щоб
ще раз не переголосувати не переписувати
Ну не виглядати смішно в очах наших
партнерів Ми наполягаємо на тому що до
речі група експертів має бути сформована
з семи представників чотири з яких мають
складати Саме ці кандидатури які
пропонуються так само і нашими
міжнародними партнерами які мають
відповідний досвід і повну незалежність
Це перша дуже важлива новела Ми
намагаємося обмежити цю До речі групу
експертів від впливу президента його
офісу Верховної Ради і таке інше тому що
зараз
закон який пропонують слуги це 6
експертів які повністю там знову
формуються офісом президента
призначається президентом парламентом
очевидно що воно більше всіх буде тільки
просувати враховуючи реалі і таке інше
Друге Ну от в законі який сьогодні
намагаються протягти більшість цікава
норма що є заступники представників до
речі групи експертів що це таке що за
заступник це смішно навіть звучить
звичайно ми вважаємо що є 7 має бути
представників які несуть повну
відповідальність за тих кандидатів яких
вони рекомендують до розгляду як суддів
Конституційного Суду і ніяких
заступників заступників заступників тут
бути не може повинна бути абсолютно
прозора процедура обрання суддів
Конституційного Суду і цей суд має бути
незалежним от на наших поправках ми
будемо наполягати так само як і вважаємо
що Вибачте будь ласка але 1 липня скоро
і Влада обіцяла і нашим партнерам по МВФ
і європейській комісії щодо липня будуть
повернуті питання декларування і таке
інше ну Вибачте будь ласка тоді треба
уже сьогодні збирати засідання Верховної
Ради України і над цим працювати Іще
одна дуже важлива історія Зараз я в наші
колеги Олексійович Марія Іонова
повернулася з Херсонщини і Донецької
області де спілкувалися із цивільними і
зв’язковими від військових дуже багато
запитань щодо роботи парламенту по-перше
вони хочуть бачити парламент от такого
щораз там на місяць десь вночі в слоті
телеканалу рада вигулькає парламент Це
ненормально взагалі канал Рада - це
ганьба нинішнього часу тому що вибачте
будь ласка в Prime times цей телеканал
показує кадри ФСБ Російської Федерації
як вони кудись на лодках на човнах
вивозять людей з Херсонщини Як таке може
бути за мільйони гривень транслюються
невідомо що просто якісь підрив
інформаційної безпеки держави в той час
коли Верховна Рада України робота
комітетів робота в парламентській
фракції просто не висвітлюється а наша
фракція взагалі знаходиться під блокадою
і під забороною
знаєте ФСБ в них друзі їх можна
показувати ці лодки а от європейську
Солідарність не можна просто ганьба ми
будемо вимагати насправді так само
звільнення нинішнього керівника
телеканалу рада тому що це якісь просто
людина яка працює з цензурою яка працює
повністю по лекалом темників епохи
медведчука Януковича і все нормально і
щоб канал Рада розповідав про ініціативи
груп фракції комітетів нормально
висвітлював діяльність верховної ради
України
Повірте військові хочуть бачити чим
займається парламент їх обурює це знаєте
коли розглядається питання народ бродить
туди-сюди такого не було 30 років такої
традиції безкультурія парламентської як
зараз відбувається в Верховній Раді є
ключове військові вимагають щоб питання
що стосуються
соціального захисту ЗСУ і інших
підрозділів
питання виплат розглядалися на кожному
засіданні і приймались конкретні рішення
ми звертаємося до президента Зеленського
закликом підписати закон який Верховна
Рада України проголосувала
конституційною більшістю щодо
врегулювання питань ВЛК і вирішення
соціальних потреб поранених І хочу
сказати що вчора дуже конструктивне було
засідання робочої групи по вирішенню
питань а-а
соціальних військовослужбовців брали
участь в ньому від наших фракцій я і
Петро Порошенко прийнято рішення про
виплати пораненим Поки людина
знаходиться в лікарні А це як правило
від місяця до трьох вона отримуватиме
сто тисяч гривень і потім від 6 місяців
до року ще 12 тисяч гривень якщо вона є
непридатною до служби частково обмеженою
в таких можливостях друге важливе
питання яке буде проголосоване на
наступному засіданні Верховної Ради це
врегулювання
питання правостороннього керма щоби такі
машини можна було ставити на баланс
підрозділів і ми тут активно попрацювали
третє дуже важливе це повернення виплат
я нагадаю що наша фракція тут зробила
максимальну кількість зусиль для того
щоб всі хто кричали що це неможливо
зрозуміли що це неправда виплати треба
повертати четверте відпустки військові
вітають збільшення відпусток і ми
пишаємося тут роботи яку провели наша
політична сила щоб військові не 10 днів
на рік мали а 30 + 10 тобто 40
загалом днів відпусток це справедливо не
останньому ще раз підняли питання щодо
несправедливості по відношенню до тих
патріотів тих добровольців які вперше
хвилини війни не втекли як СБУ і
прокуратура з Херсонщини а залишилися в
Херсоні загинули виконуючи бойові
завдання але не встигли отримати
відповідні документи і от щоб ця норма
про можливість зарахування посмертно
таких героїв до їх підрозділів була
врегульована отримали позитивне рішення
робочої групи сподіваємося що профільний
комітет нацбезпека і оборони прийметься
рішення своєму засіданні воно вже не
буде блокуватися і на наступному
пленарному засіданні утворюється блок
законів по військовим буде прийнято будь
ласка рости
Дякую Шановні колеги друзі
говорячи про вступ України до Євросоюзу
А треба назавжди запам'ятати і Це
найвища звертаємося до цього з Владою
три Прості речі перше завжди в усіх
змінах має працювати першість і головний
пріоритет демократії не буде сприйнято
як коли під маскою демократії буде
проведена монополізація влади
розчавлення свободи слова або будь-які
інші обмеження які ідуть в розріз із
європейськими цінностями тому
верховенство права свобода слова і
рівність кожного перед законом це те що
вимагає і вимагатиме Європа будь-який
законопроект який не відповідає цим
критеріям не буде сприйнятий і не буде
зарахований друге дуже важлива - це
недопустимість імітації все що робить
українська влада все що роблять
Українські політики дуже щільно
розглядається і європейськими і
українським громадянським суспільством
тому написати красиву назву і Потім
подати якийсь як завжди зміст не вийде і
ми це бачимо і по закону про
конституційний суд Про що пані Ірина
Щойно говорила і по дуже багатьох
питаннях в тому числі і по так званому
олігархічному закону про який я зараз
скажу і Третє це питання єдності
неохильна дотримання єдності яке в
попередні роки дозволено за неповні два
роки виконати 144 пункти вимог щодо
отримання безвізового режиму коли і
президент Порошенко і його команди і всі
основні фракції Верховної Ради і
признаки громадянського суспільства
працювали разом випрацьовували рішення
доводили його ухвалювали і потім
пояснювали і де треба доводили позицію
України коли
Європейський партнера могли виходити з
якихось там упереджених ставлень тоді
всі разом чітко доводилось що ні для
України це працюватиме Саме так і от
нещодавно була чергова річниця отримання
безвізу тобто можливостей нашим
громадянам їздити до Європи і коли
почалася повномасштабне вторгнення
пам'ятаємо що для мільйонів людей це
означало можливість вижити і виїхати в
безпеку тож ці три вимоги мають завжди
тримати рамку і ми бачимо що спроби
влади дещо від них відійти закінчується
тим що знову питання повертається в зал
і ми знову будемо розглядати На жаль
втрачаючи час а час зараз купується
життя ми наших воїнів тому неприпустима
будь-яке затягування от прекрасний
приклад до цього це так званий закон
щодо боротьби з олігархами з самого
початку коли це питання тільки вносилось
до зали ще перед повномасштабне
вторгненням європейська Солідарність
багато інших політичних сил і
громадських активістів говорили одну
просту річ це є закон немає нічого
спільного з боротьбою з олігархами Це
закон про те що рада нас безпеки сама
тобто чиновники призначені президентом
сама буде визначати хто олігарха хто Ні
і це буде використовуватись або для
переділу медіаринку або для політичних
репресій
практично то саме бачимо висновку
венеціанської комісії яка дуже чітко
сказала що вона бачить На жаль в цьому
законі такий персоналістський підхід
який точно буде використаний для
політичних переслідувань який немає
нічого спільного власне з боротьбою з
олігархією і тому вони натомість
пропонують застосувати системний підхід
і це рівно та позиція яку обстоює
європейська Солідарність а оцей закон
так званий про боротьбу з олігархів має
бути скасований натомість має працювати
досить цій єдності в дусі роботи разом і
залучення експертів громадянського
суспільства випрацювання пакету
реального обмеження впливу великих
грошей на політику економіку і медіа
тому що За визначенням це зловживання
владою під тиском великих грошей і тут
треба чітко виставляти бар'єри що
стосується антимонопольного
законодавства але Антимонопольний
комітет повинен перетворитися не чергове
дбр як є В тому законі який там прийняти
в першому читанні А має чітко працювати
на розділення трастів на на
унеможливлення укрупплень і інші всі
речі які уже давно майже століття
працюють в цивілізованих країнах тут
безліч прикладів можна взяти застосувати
і йти далі це питання антикорупційної
реформи доведення до завершення бо
практично половина тих критеріїв про які
говорила пані Ірина Геращенко стосується
якраз
антикорупційних речей ми бачимо що там
призначаються посадові особи і таке інше
але тут потрібен дуже щільний і
парламентський і суспільний моніторинг
щоби антикорупційні органи власна
працювали забезпечували боротьбу з
корупцією і третій дуже важливий
компонент цього пакету це забезпечення
прозорості прозорості державних
закупівель тому що яйця після 18 і
яблуко по 51 - це наруга такого не може
бути винні тут мають нести
відповідальність тому що будь-які
процедури мають бути відкриті для
суспільства і для перевірки і ми бачимо
що навіть в умовах повномасштабного
вторгнення такий нагляд це лише підвищує
ефективність і ми бачимо запитування
громадської думки що і громадяни України
абсолютно підтримують належне
Антикорупційний нагляд неналежного
прозорість от виконання цих вимог якраз
швидко наблизить Україну до
Європейського Союзу і дозволить Уже в
цьому році нарешті розпочати переговори
про повномасштабне е і повноцінне
членство і ні нам потрібно прошу проекту
третім питанням ми звісно маємо
обговорити питання бізнесу тому що
бізнес-клімат - це також одна із вимог
існування незалежної Економіки України і
тут ми маємо зосередитись на тому що
робимо ми в державі для того щоб була
можливість створювати робочі місця
забезпечувати громадян України доходами
і
обирати такий Шлях який дозволить нам не
втрачати оцю підприємницьку діяльність а
навпаки заохочувати більше людей для
того щоб ми менше покривали через різні
механізми субсидій витрати які не можуть
покрити самі домогосподарства самі
громадяни України і тут абсолютно
очевидно ми зараз з вами маємо говорити
про розгляд проекту закону 84-01 всі
його називають як повернення до воєнної
системи оподаткування
і вчора був останній день подачі
поправок саме ми від своєї фракції від
європейської солідарності подали ті
поправки які можуть конструктивно
вплинути на подальшу долю ведення тих
норм які на наш погляд на погляд
більшості
представників підприємницького
суспільства абсолютно недоречний саме в
цей час коли вони зараз запроваджуються
мені здається що наші партнери І
абсолютно Всі переговорники розуміють ту
надскладну ситуацію яка в нас є Давайте
розглянемо ці що треба робити для того
щоб в країні
продовжувався інвест-клімат на тому
рівні який він був там на 19-му році на
початку 19-го року коли насправді
інвестиції незалежні інвестиції йшли в
країну тому що
абсолютно очевидно вибу
системна робота державних органів і
контролюючих органів в рамках закону І
те що абсолютно очевидно за час воєнного
стану дуже часто ми чуємо
виправдовування що
держава потребує більше надходжень і
тому контролюючи органи дозволяють собі
повертатися в минулі часи тобто
вимагання з бізнесу якихось планових
перерахувань там штрафних санкцій і так
далі ну це точно ми не можемо допустити
сьогодні тому наші поправки стосувалися
того що ви зберегти мораторій на початок
документальних перевірок Ми не маємо
дозволяти
саме не реформовані або запущені і саме
по такому колу розвитку події виконання
функцій податкові проводити перевірки
якби у нас діяла абсолютно чітка
виконаність закону якби податкова не
порушувала їх то можливо можна би було
би і подумати але На сьогодні це точно
ні податкову треба проводити до
нових якихось стандартів автоматизувати
більшість процесів і
я розумію що навіть більшість перевірок
технічно не можна провести тому
абсолютно обґрунтовано не популістські
ми пропонуємо продовжити мораторій на
початок нових перевірок які стосуються і
документальних перевірок і порядку
сплати ЄСВ який виділений окремим у нас
нормами податкового кодексу і так далі
щодо штрафних санкцій ну дуже дико
виглядає що зараз пропонуючи повернення
до оцих саме режиму оподаткування до
війни саме передбачається за рахунок
штрафних санкцій з підприєм українців Це
мається на увазі і дрібний і середній
великий бізнес взяти додаткові кошти в
державний бюджет ну це по-перше дуже
цинічно виглядає тому що потрібно
окремим блоком говорити і якраз до цього
проекту закону ми подали поправки що
стосується підтримки юридичних осіб які
безоплатно надають товари і послуги
постраждалі території і зараз це
стосується вже не тільки збройних сил а
і просто громадян України ми маємо
розуміти що не може сплачувати юридична
особа там двічі податки якщо вона
придбає щось для того щоб надати
допомогу і це ж були важливі речі
декілька днів підряд Ми дивилися
телевізор і думали що ці кадри які
передають затоплених регіонів но вони
спонукають владу прийняти швидко такі
зміни для того щоб всі ресурси задіяти
для допомоги громадя членом України але
цього не було зроблено до речі ще одна
тема
яку яка зараз активно задається нашими
волонтерами волонтерами які збирали до
Нати для того щоб допомагати абсолютно і
дрібними військовими речами і іншими
речами для населення для громадян
території на яких велися чи ведуться
бойові дії і тут абсолютно очевидна
інформація яка періодично знову
з'являється в ЗМІ про те що волонтерів
будуть оподатковувати податком на доходи
фізичних осіб і військовим збором вона
збурює їх і тому ми теж подали поправки
щоб Волонтери які здійснюють таку
діяльність не були прив'язані в своїх
діях до якихось конкретних переліків які
абсолютно не враховують всі ті товари в
яких є необхідність і тому якраз
включення з норм які надають право без
оподаткування на на допомоги таких
переліків є правильним кроком ми маємо
навпаки заохочувати робіть все можливе
для того щоби підтримувати наших
громадян це стосується До речі і
переліків які за е більше року війни так
і не змогли спромогтися
створити в уряді затвердити їх і кабінет
міністрів Мені здається в цьому в цих
питаннях дуже багато втратив часу тому
зараз максимально треба зробити все і ми
це зробили у вигляді поправок для того
щоб ту роботу яку не виконує уряд і
Міністерства і не затверджується
Кабінетом міністрів взагалі прибрати із
норм Як такий Який зупиняють роботу
багатьох людей роботу спрямовану на
підтримку Збройних сил громадян України
На всю допомогу яка їм є і стосується
останнім питанням Я б хотіла би сказати
все-таки ще що стосується штрафів за не
застосування реєстраторів розрахункових
операцій цього найбільш очікує зараз
спільнота підприємницька буквально в
усіх регіонах проходять форуми вони
звертаються до представників влади до
всіх депутатів всіх фракції групи в
парламенті для того щоб зберегти
можливість не застосування штрафів на
період воєнного стану і ще один рік
після війни для того щоб все ж таки
підприємці продовжували свою діяльність
це та діяльність яка допомагає
утримувати їм свої родини та ще й
надавати благодійну допомогу іншим тому
зупиняти її ну це насправді просто йти
проти країни Тому це питання залишається
окремим блоком Ми будемо про це говорити
і поправки вже зареєстровані ми будемо
їх іще розміщувати нас всіх своїх
можливих площадках для того щоб кожен
громадянин мог прочитати що пропонує
європейська Солідарність
сьогодні крайня інформація яку я
отримала що до цього проекту закону
надано велику кількість поправок майже
до двох тисяч це означає що при розгляді
цього
проекту може бути застосована спеціальна
процедура А це не надасть можливість
кожному з нас представити свою точку
зору і відстоювати свою позицію щодо
кожної поправки яка подана до проекту
закону Ми вимушені сьогодні як
опозиційна фракція звернутися до всіх
наших колег в парламенті для того щоб ми
об'єдналися проаналізували кількість
поданих поправок кожною фракцією і
групою в парламенті знайшли компроміс і
публічно спільно заявили про відкликання
частини своїх поправок для того щоб
раціональна думка була почута Ми маємо
виконати в одночас і вимоги які є до
нашої країни від партнерів але і все
зробити можливе для захисту
підприємницької діяльності без
бізнес-клімату і інвестицій в нашій
країні це важливе завдання і тому я
думаю що ми зараз проведемо зустрічі з
нашими колегами і підемо по такому шляху
допустити якоїсь спецпроцедури по такому
життєважливому проекту закону просто
неможливо
будь ласка на цьому Дякуємо колеги
навіть коли немає пленарних засідань
європейська Солідарність працює в
комітетах робоча групах для того щоб
виконувати наше домашнє завдання І це
три позиції допомога збройним силам
України допомога постраждалим до
окупованим регіонам і наш шлях до ЄС і
НАТО маємо його пройти якнайшвидше і
стати членами цих важливих для нас
об'єднань дякую